erste frage wann habe ich geburtstag
herzlich willkommen wie die leute im
heutigen video lasse ich meine
geschwister gegeneinander antreten
hierdurch schon eher gewünscht es mal
wieder video kommt in dem meine
schwester dabei ist und heute ist es so
meine schwester ist dabei und ich teste
wäre ich besser kennt mein bruder meine
schwester fahren wir ja gern mal den
fragen hier sein bruder max was geht ich
meine programme und hier oder nicht hier
ist mein schwester ok erste frage und
die frage gibt spezielle meine schwester
warum hast du max und nicht auf
instagram blockiert
ok dann fangen wir den hauptzweig ich
habe zehn fragen erste frage wann habe
ich geburtstag
prodrive am 14 1995 2
das ist relativ man acht mal im jahr
sagt zumindest im monat also zu den
monatlichen bekommen oder irgendwas mit
was meine schuhe größe
ich denke denken ist schon 46 41 sieht
dass wir noch 41 aus ja ok welche
gerichte also welches ersten klasse ich
nenn 3 du hast ob wie viel zum gericht
ist okay okay alles wird irgendwie dann
hast du so zum beispiel das nur zum
becher mail soße und außerdem irgendwas
was mir schmeckt
irgendwas ist ja auch kein gericht dar
wie alt war ich halte ich zum studium
ausgezogen bin als ich weiß dass die
sehr früh gemacht mit 16
dann hast du irgendwie hat es ja soziale
arbeitet soziale arbeit gemacht jetzt
natürlich frage warst du schon 17 hast
du bist oder was du noch 16 ich tippe
aber auf 17 17
da warst du
du hast ein jahr pause gemacht und weil
sich die 19
übersetzt was ja 19 17h mit 16
weißt du das mieten eines lust bei den
jusos mit ok wie lange war ich in indien
ein oder zwei monate ich glaube dass
nach einem monat und zwei wochen
abgebrochen also ich wirklich für woche
sechs wochen
und 4 was da für ein halbes jahr ein
halbes jahr am monate war 707 monat
sieben monate
jetzt kommt es zu der frage wie ist mein
lieblings
[Musik]
ich habe alles falsch ich habe jetzt
hast du mir da irgendwas begrenzt wie
ist mein lieblingslehrer in der schule
das ist die richtige antwort okay welche
klasse habe nicht übersprungen also ich
hab eine klasse übersprungen leute
welche war es war nicht die sind ja
nicht die achte klasse noch in der
grundschule sagt okay wir machen sagt
burger vor den fluten wirst du sagst mit
die klasse und dann die 14 sah keine 99
okay was mein bestes fach in der schule
nicht gemacht also wo du die beste note
im abschluss sondern das ist ja nee also
allgemein über die jahre hinweg fester
mutter
ich glaube du wat seine in astrup
ziemliches setzt eher auf spaß gemacht
hat ich spanisch oder mein bestes fach
in der schule spanisch hatte ich nicht
mehr
jetzt höre ich jetzt gleich du kannst
doch spanisch da habe ich doch danach
gelernt und spanien englisch okay die
nächsten zeit folgen sind schätzfrage so
ein bisschen was war meine schnellste
laufzeit auf zehn kilometern also zehn
kilometer joggt wie schnell sich
gespalten ist gedruckt wurden
ich glaube eine halbe stunde pro ich
weiß nicht genau was machst du das nicht
mehr geht hat jede woche zwei hd also
jetzt muss ich ganz tief liegt jetzt
zwei minuten
ich habe keinen schimmer hatte er aber
gesagt alter wisst ihr wie schnell 30
minuten auf zehn kilometer sind was ist
das höchste tempo das ich jemals
gefahren bin also was ihr den tacho
gezeigt 289 289 den keller drückt aber
260 das tempo bis der tacho gezeigt hat
also zu wissen der tacho zeigt ein
bisschen mehr an als man wirklich fährt
also ein bisschen hoch
60 mein jetziger ist aber noch schneller
als tippen papa okay dann 310 stammen
dann nicht 290 das ist eine sehr gute
zahl das trifft alles klar dann checke
gute antworten
also ich nicht so gute antworten zu
machen dass ich gewinne dann kommen wir
zur auswertung der bergung mit auch mal
aufs sofa erzählt jetzt einfach an der
hand eure punkte mit die erste frage
wann habe ich geburtstag habe er falsch
max richtig ein punkt schuhgröße beide
richtig weil der punkt welche gerichte
hass ich ja ihr krieg war ein punkt war
jetzt im studio ausgezogen bin max
kriegen punkt wie lange reichen indien
beide falsch von vier wochen
max ein bisschen näher am markt den
punkt geführt
der hätte 67 monat wie ich mein lieb
mich die räder der schule bei den punkt
welche klubs wachsen pumpt wasser
bestens fach in der schule wachsen punkt
was war meine schnellste laufzeit auf
zehn kilometern
ich bin so ein typischer marathonläufer
alter ich meine chefs zeit waren 48
minuten also punkt was ist das höchste
tempo das ich jemals gefahren wenn
meiner meinung nach was auf dem tacho
287 aber du sagst 189 habe er war auch
mega damit 290 aber unabhängig davon ob
es zu 180 über 780 waren max kriegt auch
den punkt ich habe zehn die gewissen
hast du jeden fall richtig
also kann man strich sagen max kennt
mich ein bisschen besser zumindest
könnte die frage besser beantworten aber
wir sind auch schon länger zusammen auf
der welt und du warst einfach älter und
konnte mehr erinnern als die dinge
passiert sind daher dass trotzdem gute
punkte geholt und hier leute kommt
sondern was das geht die ist mit einer
zusammen mit meiner co-moderatorin die
hat nicht würdig vertreten und eine
folge über streaming dienste gemacht ist
das jetzt gar nicht abdecken und und
lernt so aus wenn die kosten über nicht
gelernt hat sollte